sinon il ya beaucoup de sourires un
plaisir une bonne ambiance et pouvoir la
casse est parfait alors là je voudrais
commencer en posant une question est ce
que il ya déjà des gens parmi ceux qui
se sont sentis un peu déprimé en
regardant les infos moi aussi
et d'ailleurs cette tablette visiblement
à lahti mal à supporter l'état du monde
pareil que moi je me suis déjà sentie
débordés submergés comme ça dans dans un
flux en continu avec toutes les infos
présenté sur le même plan aucune
hiérarchie l'impression en plus que tous
les événements sont présentés comme
étant déconnectés les uns des autres
comme si il n'y avait aucun lien entre
les armes gouvernement vende au
moyen-orient le mal être grandissant de
nombreuses personnes parmi nos
concitoyens et les attentats terroristes
aucun rapport bien sûr donc oui il ya de
quoi déprimer 1
alors on m'a souvent dit de manière très
bienveillante qu'il fallait que c'est
près de 100 et noir que j'arrête de
déprimer à vous à l'état du monde parce
que ça ne pouvait rapporter toute la
misère du monde sur les épaules et que
de toute façon c'est pas moi qui allait
bien et changer quelque chose
alors le problème c'est que pour moi ça
ça revenait à dire devient comme les
adultes cynique blasé et déconnecte toit
des autres et du monde ça évidemment je
voulais pas même si c'est vrai que dans
un univers où tu es spam et d'image
ultra violente
le détachement sa relève carrément de la
survie quoi mais malgré ça on peut pas
s'empêcher de se dire qu'ils nous
racontent toujours la même chose qui
nous mentent voir que nous en face de
nous exprimer encore jeudi histoire de
qui le fameux e et politique les médias
responsable de toute la misère du monde
coupable d'être déconnecté de nous et de
nos vies coupable de nous manipuler pour
leurs intérêts personnels en pourquoi
pas coupable au final deux
prendre pour le tout alors qu'ils ne
sont comme nous une partie du monde que
des petites gouttes d'eau alors on
s'enferme dans sa solitude et on se
raccroche pour tenir le coup pour se
dire qu'on n'est pas en train de devenir
complètement cinglé à des citations
inspirante
si vous n'y prenez pas garde les médias
vous feront haïr les opprimés aimé leurs
oppresseurs malcom x
ce n'est pas un signe de bonne santé
mentale que d'être bien adapté à une
société malade
didou krishna more thing en fin de
compte c'est bien de gaulle ou
shakespeare où jésus je sais plus par
rapporte en tout cas il avait raison les
français sont des veaux et on se résigne
condamné à ne servir à rien impuissant
face à engrais ci qui résonne de manière
toujours plus lointaine mais parfois ce
sentiment là il fait naître autre chose
si le fameux ceux qui sont supposés
parce que c'est leur boulot donner du
sens au monde autour de nous parler de
nous et nous parler à nous ne le sont
pas alors qui va le faire je fais partie
d'un groupe de gens qui en a eu marre
d'être blasé qui je sais pas si c'est
dit à un moment faut faire quelque chose
on s'est retrouvé face à un choix soit
on continuait à rager après les médias
c'est ce qu'à la fin des temps soit on
faisait et ont montré qu'on était
capable de faire au moins aussi bien que
au moins et c'est ce qu'on a fait donc
on a fait un journal as ont un téléphone
qu'on n'avait pas de chaînes de télé et
encore moins d'argent pour en acheter
une
du coup on a fait ça comme tout le monde
un sur internet donc l'idée c'était un
journal pour donner du sens là où il y
en avait plus pourquoi qu'on n'était pas
assez occupés chacun avec une routine
nos vies respectives et qu'on se dit
ballon sinon on va tous apprendre à
faire sur le tas un truc pour lequel
aucun d'entre nous les former et vous
rendent le truc encore plus facile on va
s'astreindre à le faire toutes les
semaines un an
la semaine le jeudi je sais pas pourquoi
on s'est dit ça parce qu'en fait ça on
est parti du coup pour plusieurs années
de dette de sommeil mais bon peu importe
il fallait bien que quelqu'un le fasse
du coup comme personne ne faisait bas on
s'est dit on va faire parce que cette
somme de solides tout individu n qu'on
voyait autour de nous dans le monde
vous êtes est vraiment insupportable
parce qu' il fallait justement que
toutes ces gouttes d'eau se rencontrent
et se rendre compte qu'elle formait
partie d'un tout le grand qu'elle
un nouveau récit c'était notre mission
offrir un nouveau récit alors quand tu
auras envie un nouveau récit je ne dis
pas ouais alors va remonter des
histoires
c'était pas du tout moore de départ nous
ce qu'on voulait faire c'était vraiment
redonner du sens là où il y en avait
plus à partir des feuilles qui existait
mais qui vous semblait vraiment
totalement déconnectés les uns des
autres dans l'immédiat donc bon on a
essayé de faire ce à partir du point de
vue des gouttes d'eau dont on ne parle
jamais mais qui pourtant font tourner le
monde au quotidien en évoquant par
exemple comment directement les lois
avait un impact sur notre vie
quotidienne ou ce que voulait dire
concrètement pour nous dans la vie
réelle les chiffres la vie réelle partir
du réel
on nous adresser aux autres groupes de
en fait c'était ça l'idée montrer que
les problèmes qu'on ressent de manière
individuelle
en fait ce sont des problèmes des
expériences des réalités qui sont
partagés montré qu'en quand les
partageant en se reconnectant les uns
aux autres on pouvait les rendre un peu
moins insurmontable dans le texte et qui
sait en en discutant ensemble peut-être
même voyante et trouver des solutions
on sait pas et il s'est passé un truc de
fou
c'est que c'est quand on a fait un
épisode sur l'immigration suite à la
crise des migrants à calais vous dit
s'il vous plaît et en fait justement
l'idée de la vidéo c'était surtout pas
de prendre parti de défendre une
position ou une autre qui préexistait
déjà ça c'était pas du tout ce qui nous
intéressait on ne voulait surtout pas
donner l'impression qu'on privilégier le
point de vue ou même la souffrance de
certains par rapport au point de vue ou
à la souffrance d'autres groupes de
personnes
nous ce qu'on a voulu faire c'est
prendre du recul interrogé le problème
dans sa globalité dans sa totalité avec
toutes les implications que ça
comportait est injectée juste un peu de
bon sens dans son ensemble et être ou
faut le dire un peu une hystérie
générale
donc on a fait ça et les conséquences de
cette vidéo ont été absolument
incroyable c'est que la vidéo a été aimé
partager commenter discuté par tout un
ensemble de gens des gouttes d'eau qui a
priori ne se rencontrent jamais ne
discute pas on tremble jamais c'est à
dire on a eu des gens qui émanait de
tout le spectre politique et apolitique
qui sont mises à échanger à discuter
ensemble à partager des opinions dans le
respect de l'autre sans forcément
changer de point de vue un de toute
façon tout le monde n'a pas changé de
point de vue
c'était pas c'est pas évident mais on
s'est rendu compte rangée quelque chose
peut-être y aller au delà de simplement
partager un petit point de vue de
petites gouttes d'eau c'est qu'on était
en train de me créer ou en tout cas
d'aménager un espace qui permettait à
des gens qui d'habitude ne se
rencontrent jamais la d'interagir et
pourquoi pas de se trouver des choses en
commun
on a aménagé un espace de commun une
communauté est pas pour rien ça
s'appelle comme ça en fête et danser
rendu compte qu'on était
un point dans une petite cellule dans un
vaste réseau au même titre est au même
niveau que toutes les autres cellules
qui reçoit et qui on voit de
l'information à tout ce qui est connecté
au réseau
si vous regardez notre corps le corps
humain il fut comme ça portait un
ensemble de cellules infiniment petit
qui toutes ensemble forment l'identité
forme agressive du soin il n'y a pas
vraiment de possibilités ou en tout cas
d'utilité pour une cellule d'exister
tout seul et en même temps il ya un
maillon manquant et l'information
circule plus et c'était ça la première
leçon on a retenu en tout cas sur
d'autres mais nous avons la première
leçon c'était ça on n'a pas besoin en
fait de choisir entre conserver son
identité propre où se fondre dans une
identité collective c'est qu'on est les
deux ont fait partie d'un collectif mais
on a chacun notre identité personnelle
la première leçon il ya eu leur deuxième
moment qui nous a marqués dans
l'histoire petit groupe février 2016
on sortait avec l'équipe d'un dîner avec
un homme qui depuis a été candidat
malheureux à l'élection présidentielle
stein blague je pense qu'il voulait
qu'on bosse pour lui ça s'est pas très
bien passé parce que nous on n'était pas
très jours notre but n'était pas de
faire la propagande politique mais bon
par politesse ci va quand même
du coup ils nous avaient demandé des
conseils sur sa chaîne youtube qui à
l'époque avait très peu d'abonnés mais
bon ça c'était fini sur lui qui me
disaient ouais moi je n'ai pas
disneyland jeter la politique retourner
faire les kékés d'accord soit c'est ce
qu'on a fait je précise au passage que à
cette période là je traversé
dire un passage à vide c'est un
euphémisme pour dire que j'étais en
arrêt maladie pour dépression
j'étais sous anti dépresseurs
d'anxiolytiques pour les des somnifères
la totale tout un tas de trucs que merci
je ne prends plus je vais mieux mais ce
n'était pas facile et le seul truc qui
faisait que me sentais utile à la
communauté autour de moi c'était ça
c'était d'aller filmer toutes les
semaines ce petit journal avec les
copains qui venait me chercher parce que
j'avais peur de sortir de chez moi tout
seul bref un je ne sais pas comment ça
s'est passé la caméra parce que parce
que franchement j'étais pas bien et bon
je devais avoir un très bon compte 1
française lui je porte aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs mais bref donc deux jours
après ce dîner assez surréaliste le
gouvernement publiait son projet de loi
intitulé what travaille pas entendu
parler donc ce projet de loi travail
complet il nous semblait à nous des
choses qui allaient vraiment rendre un
quotidien on travaille on vivait une
gossip encore plus difficile était déjà
du coup on s'est dit il faut absolument
qu'on n'utilise même super pouvoirs de
mickey pour faire quelque chose à ce
sujet donc on a contacté nos copains
final de jack et dingo qui ont mis en
marche leur réseau disneyland aussi qui
ont compté noir et en fait avec plein de
vidéastes qui aussi faisait disneyland
sur internet
on sait tous connectés ensemble et on a
fait une vidéo pour sensibiliser
l'opinion à l'existence de ce projet de
loi la vidéo ne s'appelait pas la bande
à mickey mais en tout cas dans cette
vidéo il y avait chacun nous qui disait
un de petites phrases alors que tout à
l'heure à 1 debout tu rases isolé ça
sert pas à grand chose mais tous
ensemble ça donnait un texte et une
vidéo qui franchement ils sont plein de
modestie était vraiment très bien et
déjà ça en soit c'était une formidable
expérience de reconnexion mais ça ne
s'est pas arrêté là
parce que dans la vidéo
j'en vois j'ai ce qui était spectateur à
devenir des acteurs pas juste en
partageant notre vidéo
merci c'est sympa les gars mais en
partageant une expérience c'est à dire
qu'on a encouragé les gens à partager
leur ressenti d'un quotidien au travail
qui était difficile et que cette loi
allait empirer
donc la vidéo a fait plusieurs millions
de vues en quelques jours il ya des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
se sont saisis du hashtag qu'on avait
proposé on vaut mieux que ça et qui sont
mis à à partager des des récits de leurs
expériences up et là se sont mis à
pleuvoir des témoignages de harcèlement
de deux heures non payées de conditions
de travail indignes ou dangereuses
il était absolument pas du négatif c'est
que le hashtag nous avait échappé
vous appartenez plus la sociale parce
que c'était un point de ralliement sur
les réseaux sociaux
mais il était aussi utilisé dehors dans
la rue par les manifestants qui
défilaient contre la voix travail il y
avait des gens à la télé c'est en parler
nous on est allé à la télé pour parler
de ça donc c'est un peu où quand même et
comme en écho en plus sa monnaie et ça
nous enseigner des choses sur nous mêmes
c'est à dire qu'à titre personnel j'ai
appris que j'étais pas qu'une seule avec
mes angoisses en fait parce que en plus
mais en quoi ce qui était en grande
partie due au travail ça tombait bien
ça m'a montré aussi que formuler un
problème en parler c'est déjà le début
d'une solution
et du coup c'est un peu comme si on
avait tous levé la tête
soudain vous souhaitez regarder
conserver cette géniale en fait on n'est
pas tout seul à devoir porter un fardeau
individuellement troll ou pour nous non
non on est une communauté de gens qui
est là pour s'épauler pour partager les
coûts durant y en a et aussi pour se
donner mutuellement de l'espoir alors
récemment il ya quelqu'un qui n'a fait
remarquer dans un commentaire très
bienveillant que je devrais me reposer
et arrêtez d'essayer
videos y en avait qu'un des avoués et
rétrospectivement on a fait six ans je
me suis dit oui quand même s'est
peut-être un peu ça que pensé qu'il
fallait faire quand vous voulez faire
quelque chose de juste votre bon dans ce
monde s'atteler tout seul à essayer dé
l'océan avec le dé à coudre et petits à
souffrir parce qu'on n'y arrivait pas
mais depuis j'ai appris à part que j'ai
appris que faire le mic et c'est quand
même pas si mal que ça j'ai appris que
tout seul une goutte d'eau en tout cas
tout seul ne peut pas porter toute la
misère du monde effectivement parce que
la misère du monde avec beaucoup trop
lent pour une goutte d'eau tout seul
par contre ce que j'ai aussi appris
c'est que ce qui est impossible pour une
goutte d'eau ça devient possible quand
cette goutte d'eau se reconnecte à
d'autres boulots et va dans un processus
de création et de dépassement de soi
j'ai appris également que dans le
dépassement de soi il ya forcément ce
moment d'agréation et échappe parce que
en partageant quelque chose une
expérience ça entre en résonance avec la
communauté à la fois individuellement et
collectivement
et c'est ce moment là en fait ce qui
fait naître quelque chose de bien plus
puissant que la solitude alors au final
être une goutte d'eau ses ailes trop si
légitime ses avoirs autant de pouvoir de
changer les choses autour de soi que
n'importe quel autre boulot dans le
monde
il suffit juste de se rappeler qu'on
n'est jamais une partie d'un tout qui
est plus grand que soi
isolé oui on est condamné à la
frustration de ne pas pouvoir vider
l'océan avec ses mains mais qu en se
reconnectant à soi-même à l'autre et à
ce tout l'océan c'est nous merci
[Applaudissements]